tras una noche de conteo frenético
marruecos tiene resultados provisionales
de sus elecciones parlamentarias
se esperaba que un cambio en el sistema
de votación dificultará los partidos
grandes obtener mayorías y es
exactamente lo que pasó
el partido reagrupación nacional de
independientes obtuvo 97 escaños el
partido autenticidad y modernidad de 82
escaños
el partido istiqlal 78 escaños el
partido justicia y desarrollo 12
con más del 90 por ciento del voto
escrutado el partido justicia y
desarrollo que estaba en el poder desde
la primavera árabe hace 10 años sufrió
una derrota demoledora de los 125
escaños que tenían perdieron 113 contra
los partidos liberales incluidos sus
principales rivales el partido
autenticidad y modernidad y el partido
istiqlal de centroderecha
pero el mayor ganador de la noche fue el
partido reagrupación nacional de
independientes en coalición con justicia
y desarrollo desde hace cuatro años
ganaron 60 escaños para asegurar el
primer lugar
según el ministro del interior la
participación subió siete puntos
respecto a 2016 superando el 50 por
ciento
marruecos es una monarquía
constitucional donde la corona tiene
amplios poderes incluida la designación
de ministros claves y el diseño de la
agenda económica del país lo más
probable es que el partido ganador deba
buscar una coalición para superar los
198 escaños necesarios para formar una
mayoría queda en espera la designación
de un nuevo primer ministro por parte
del rey